and rely of a very serious important
question for you hi everybody shut up
Oh what's your favorite thing about
marklar everything your eyes his eyes
and his voice my eyes and voice
especially when he smiles because it
seemed so well it's okay I'm age I can
say this Thanks okay what's your
favorite thing about Mark what else fits
that doesn't make any so I scream like a
lady in them fit yeah that's not very
very good compliment thank you bye
forever so if you're trapped on an
island with your whole family who would
you eat first
I like how you're taking this question
so seriously but seriously I want to
know the answer okay so she could cook
up your sister and it'd just be
delicious okay all right
[Music]
okay anyway what's your favorite thing
about my channel your charity stream is
actually better or not really yeah first
one to say that and I'm really happy
that someone finally mentioned it yeah
man absolutely I respect that it's
awesome thank you so much cuz everyone
else depends I can you scream your
stupid face
no dude you know it those are good all
right all right what's your favorite
thing about market Punk minecraft right
oh calls bad for you kid don't drink
it's bad but it's funny Verena so if
you're trapped in the room with an
amnesia monster what would you okay my
craft because I use it to play Dungeons
& Dragons you're trapped in the room
with that amnesia monster what do you do
ah too late you're dead okay thank you
bye okay quick question if you two were
trapped on an island together who would
eat a news first
ud her i was pretty quick
looks like you don't have a choice in
back hope you have fun anyway these are
the cannibal sisters here okay anything
funny to say support my player okay
if kittens could fly would that be
terrifying or awesome
that's gonna weird say awesome awesome I
think it'd be terrifying the little rats
yeah no one's gonna like that yeah dance
break dance dance with me dance dance
dance
kittens couldn't why would that be
awesome good answer
okay thank you so much okay Duncan
you're trapped in the room with him
amnesia muscle what do you do run in
scream good answer there we got a pool
you're the only one who didn't die when
I asked that question so what's your
favorite thing about my channel the
scarce skiers the last and the last all
right thanks so much
okay so if you and your three friends
over there
we're trapped on an island who would eat
who probably everyone you would eat
everyone would you let that happen okay
I think everyone od'd each other today
I've got a question but if cats could
fly would that be awesome
just think about Kent playing on your
face and scratching it that's terrifying
that's beautiful thank you
what's your favorite thing about my
channel favorite thing about your
channel is your reaction yeah but
everyone likes me screaming like a
little baby girl anything else no that's
it that's it
okay so hi this is what's its face Sam
yeah whatever what's your favorite thing
about my channel um you that's the
second time zone said that me what else
I like how you give intelligent
commentary on the games you're playing
and not just random crew humor me
intelligent shut up nurse okay you're
trapped in the room with that means
imposter what do you do hey everybody
this is Ryan I wanted to ask you right
now what's your favorite thing about
market walk by your beauty fine